bonjour daniel cardinaux oui bonjour
mais signer un temps vous êtes donc sur
cette liste menée par benoît hamon la
liste génération pour les élections
européennes du 26 mai policière très
loin en 52e position sur une liste a
crédité de moins de 2% des intentions de
vote
qu'est ce qui vous motive encore daniel
terminaux dans cette lutte alors
toujours et la même chose c'est-à-dire
l' urgence climatique l'urgence
environnementale l'urgence sociale
l'urgence démocratique nous avons besoin
vraiment d'avancé d'avancer beaucoup
plus vite que ce que nous faisons
actuellement
on reviendra très rapidement sur vos
objectifs à travers cette campagne mais
notre chaîne d'information française
politique et ce matin qu'il manque quand
même un peu d'argent à benoît hamon pour
financer sa campagne des élections à peu
près six cent mille euros et pour
financer des bulletins de vote et des
professions de foi de ses candidats là
encore c'est une nouvelle épine dans le
pied
eh bien écoutez c'est un petit peu tous
les partis je pense que vous avez déjà
entendu les crânes funding où les levée
de fonds de certains autres partis mais
nous aussi nous allons appeler à la
générosité de nos sympathisants et puis
de nos militants
la gauche qui n'arrive pas à recoller
les morceaux c'est ça votre drame
surtout depuis la présidentielle aucune
leçon n'a été tirée pourquoi cette
gauche continue à se morceler le
pourquoi je ne saurais pas mais bon il y
as certainement effectivement des leçons
à en tirer
moi je regrette personnellement je
regrette qu'on ne fasse pas plus
d'unions bien sûr parce que on a pas mal
de choses en convergence mais
aujourd'hui nous allons vers les
européennes avec une une idée une façon
de prendre ça très au sérieux
et puis d'essayer de faire un espèce de
mouvement transnational le printemps
européen auquel nous adhérons c'est une
un mouvement qui est présent dans 10
pays en europe et qui porte partout la
même la même vision d'une europe plus
libre plus juste plus écologique
c'est pour cela que vous aimeriez quand
même une petite réforme du mode
d'élection vous aimeriez par exemple qui
est des listes qu'on parle de listes
européennes pourraient avoir ça on
pourrait avoir de certains sièges
disponibles pour des listes
transnationales sera difficile soit il
ya eu déjà un premier vote ce qui a été
rejeté mais on peut toujours travailler
sur ce sur ce sujet là puisque de toute
façon si vous voulez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que les listes sont
nationales les gens se regroupent après
dans des des groupes qui sont faits un
peu des fois de broc emploi voilà on
voit par exemple comment le parti
principal a des problèmes avec des gens
comme urban et donc nous nous avons une
autre logique c'est de mettre d'abord
notre nos idées ensemble sur l'europe et
après nous nous menons ça ce pays par
pays
alors génération la liste de besoins
hamon génération avec un s je les
rassure avec magie des nations unies
vous défendez une gauche écologique la
sauvegarde de l'environnement tout le
monde s'y réfèrent mais la destruction
de la planète se poursuit inexorablement
en quoi cette élection du 26 mai
pourrait changer la donne
eh bien écoutez nous ce que nous
proposons c'est un new deal et m
vraiment vraiment vraiment le paquet sur
la transition écologique en mettant 500
milliards d'euros
les donner aux banques les données pour
cette transition écologique parce que ça
coûte cher ça coûte cher de changer nos
habitudes ça coûte cher de rénover les
bâtiments pour éviter de consommer de
l'énergie d'ailleurs par exemple
l'énergie la plus propre
c'est celle qu'on ne consomme pas donc
nous avons cette idée de vraiment frappé
très fort
comment faire passer un tel discours à
travers aux scouts à qui
traditionnellement n'attire pas grand
monde
alors ça c'est le drame surtout en
martinique je rappelle les chiffres de
la participation de
de la dernière haie européenne une
question 11,42 % de votants ça veut dire
que 88% et quelques de gens ne vont pas
se déplacer alors là c'est un drame
parce que c'est c'est vraiment l'europe
c'est c'est vraiment le lieu des
pouvoirs y aurait pas autant de lobby
avec autant de puissance si si les les
les enjeux n'étaient pas là et
d'ailleurs joué dans tous les sens je
voudrais faire remarquer que l'extrême
droite ne s'y trompe plus l'extrême
droite qui prônait le frac site qui
prônait la sortie les nationalismes et
c'est maintenant s'unissent pour prendre
le pouvoir sur l'europe et ça c'est très
longue
ce discours qui a changé et cette union
d'aider des parties d'ultra droite sur
sur l'europe est très dangereuse c'est
contre ça eh bien écoutez justement nous
sommes là aujourd'hui les populismes les
populismes justement si on arrive à ce
thème niveau de l'an passé parce que ça
répond quand même quelques
préoccupations majeures le nervi écouter
ce que nous nous sommes en train de dire
partout c'est l'urgence et je disais à
la fois environnementale est à la fois
social c'est ce que disent certains fin
du monde et fins de mois un cellier et
bien comprendre qu'il ya deux façons de
lutter la première ses choix soient même
chez soi et il ya plein d'initiatives en
martinique qui se lève et je suis très
heureuse de voir ça depuis quelques
années les plastiques attaque les
nettoyages de plages les plans on plante
des arbres fruitiers etc
voilà donc ça c'est le local b par
rapport aux normes ce et c'est bien des
petites choses de la base c'est bien il
faut que çà çà çà progresse et après il
faut il faut attaquer ans et il faut que
les gens comprennent que leur bulletin
de vote c'est important c'est très
important
et au niveau de l'europe justement alors
au niveau local vous avez parlé de ces
petites mains qui vont nettoyer les
plages qui tire toutes les sonnettes
d'alarmé comment vous vous y prendrez
vous irez voir toutes ces associations
toutes ces individualités qui agissent
au quotidien pour la sauvegarde de
l'environnement pour lui
26 mai va voter pourquoi pas non mais
déjà je participe et je les rencontre
oui bien sûr et puis bon ben nous sommes
là pour pour cette campagne si vous
l'aviez rappeler je suis en 52e position
sur une liste et c'est donc je ne suis
pas là pour être élue je suis là pour
dire aux gens combien c'est important
et combien il faut prendre au sérieux
cette élection européenne et m
effectivement des gens qui sont capables
damman d'amener plus de liberté et plus
de démocratie plus de lien social de
solidarité et de et de sensations
économique
la difficulté c'est que ce discours est
quand même véhicule et par d'autres
formations europe écologie verts le
parti socialiste et même certains thèmes
qui se retrouve par exemple dans la
liste dans la liste renaissance c'est là
la difficulté pour vous donc l'année
votre tellement de ceux des autres
écoutez ce que je disais c'est que notre
logique était la logique transnationales
cesse je pense que c'est ce qui nous ce
qui nous distingue mais sinon je pousse
à ce qu'on aille voter quand votre mais
de voter même si vous votez pour pour
d'autres que nous qui me portent ce
genre d'idées mais cette élection est
sérieuse cette élection est vraiment
sérieuse les lieux de pouvoir que
représente la commission et le parlement
européen sont importants et décide
beaucoup de notre de notre vie de tous
les jours donc il faut y aller
conscience davantage en martinique
je ne sais pas assez loin de toute façon
le crédit sur la classe politique dans
son ensemble à tous les niveaux que ce
soit à l'échelle l'échelon très local
avec la mairie jusqu'à un niveau plus
fort pour nous là c'était mais plus au
sud au delà au niveau national je ne
sais pas si si c'est un une défiance
vis-à-vis des politiques oui on a
toujours le sentiment que le bulletin de
vote ne sert à rien mais c'est ça qu'il
faut que les gens aient de l'action il
faut il faut se détromper le bulletin de
vote est utile est important et
justement aussi ce que nous essayons
d'apporter quand je dis plus de
démocratie c'est ça aussi c'est à dire
qui
on sent bien que les gens en ont assez
de mettre un chèque en blanc tous les
cinq ans en votant pour quelqu'un et
puis après voilà donc il faut qu'il y
ait après un suivi un suivi des citoyens
et nous proposons par exemple nous
d'avoir un lobby citoyens à bruxelles
c'est à dire des gens qui vous dénoncez
le lobbying vous êtes prêt à faire un
lobby citoyens c'est à dire des citoyens
qui iront demander des comptes et qui
rend appuyé sur sur les décisions du
parlement et de la commission
ce pour combattre ce discrédit vis-à-vis
de la classe politique c'est peut-être
pour cela que des citoyens se se
projette davantage dans la vie
associative dans ses actions de tous les
jours
au quotidien je pense c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je répète je répète il
faut faire les deux c'est à dire il faut
vraiment travailler sur le niveau local
le niveau associatif mais il faut aussi
se rendre compte que au niveau national
supranationale on a notre important
c'est notre mot à dire et que c'est ça
nous engage voilà daniel cardinaux qui
est membre a fait qu'ils co listière sur
cette liste aunis menée par benoît hamon
pour les élections européennes du 26 mai
génération avec f
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
dans son caddie bonne journée je vous
remercie monsieur attend
[Musique]